Angela's with us in Little Rock Arkansas
hi Angela how are you good thank you so
much for taking my call
sure what's up well I have three
teenagers and this call is about my
oldest teenager who just finished her
freshman year of college
she's our first pancake and the pancake
isn't very round right now that's a
great saying oh my she has always been a
hard worker she worked 30 hours a week
all through high school getting her
honors diploma worked hard in the
summers never gave us a bit of trouble
but about six months ago she started
dating a guy she knew from high school
and he was about three hours away at
another college and he just moved home
for the summer they just finished their
first year beginning of May and moved
back in with his mom is working
part-time and he overheard a
conversation between us about working
full-time this summer and he expressed
to her that he was concerned they might
not have a good summer together if she
was working full-time so at her new job
she has been averaging about 16 hours a
week that's all they've been giving her
and we have urged her that she needs to
get a second and third job and over the
past month there have been a lot of
conversations of her and not real
motivated to get any more jobs right now
so we told her that she was going to
have to move out and we moved her out
last Thursday into some college
apartment she took a college loan out
herself that paid for about half of it
and I really thought that she would
start to feel some urgency when she got
her own place but I think because of
that loan it just hasn't registered and
she still has not gotten anything more
than the 15 hours the thing that we have
left here we're not afraid of tough love
because we have moved her out but we
have been letting her use our vehicle to
go back and forth to work but she seems
to mostly be you
to drive 30 minutes to her boyfriend's
house so we're a little fed up we we
really don't know what to do next we
need your advice but also she has
announced that she plans to transfer
three hours away to his college and get
her scholarship up and it's going to
cost her quite a bit more so do you have
any advice for me painful I'm sorry it's
it's hard to watch your kids do stupid
stuff on well I mean you only have two
methods of persuasion with kids in these
situations and one is the amount of
economics that your any any support
you're providing which you are
one-by-one removing those support items
I can hear that and then the only other
method you've got is persuasion right
and so it's like if you were sitting
down with your friends 19 year old kid
you would have nothing but persuasion
right and what would you do then well
you would say you know I did some stupid
stuff when I was in college and you're
even dumber or not was I mean it's
unbelievable how stupid you are I mean
you'd have to somehow get that message
across you wouldn't do it that way
obviously but I mean you'd have to make
a connection and go really I mean you're
gonna you're gonna have you're gonna
walk with a limp for a decade with the
decisions you're making right here
you're gonna mess your life up and so
you know persuasion is all you got Anna
I assume you've tried some of that but
you would use if you're doing that you
would not use your mom voice you would
use your coach voice and you would not
use mom sentences you would use coach
sentences and so what part is her dad
playing in this conversation
Oh talk to her
we have both talked to her about this
together separate we just the only thing
that we we tried everything persuasive
that we can think of to try to get
through the mm-hmm well I mean I think
you know I don't know I can't tell but I
the stance that Sharon and I took with
ours was that we're not going to
financially support bad decisions and
that would include cars and money and
anything else I mean we're not gonna if
you're gonna do things we don't agree
with you're gonna do it on your own dime
because and the reason we don't agree
with it is not because of us it's
because we care about you we love you
and you are you're bringing harm to
yourself with a series of decisions and
so you know and we're not gonna
participate in you doing things that
bring harm to you and whether that's
behaviors or lack of grades or who
you're dating or who you're hanging
around with or whatever else we maintain
control of that and have a say in that
as long as we have economics involved in
now if we don't have economics involved
and all we have left is persuasion so
yeah I mean I would have probably done
similar things to what you're doing
other than I wouldn't have taken out a
loan for anything wouldn't it
participated in that but other than that
I mean this sounds like similar things
but you know and so let me send you a
copy of Meg Meekers book strong father
our hero I don't know if we have hero
here let's send strong father's strong
daughters the relationship between a
daughter and a dad if there's a good dad
in the picture it can really go a long
way and you know him sitting down with
this young man face-to-face and
explaining to him what he is doing to
your daughter I mean I would bust on
this kid I've done it before and you
know and so and it's not that I'm trying
to be mean or just run this kid off but
you know he is bringing negative stuff
he's being immature he's bringing
negative stuff into this in your
daughter's life and I don't care if
she's 28 I'm gonna speak into that I'm
her dad and all your control freaks no
I'm her dad God gave me that purpose he
gave me that privilege and what would
you do about the car right now would you
in publishers pay towards it I probably
take it I'd probably take it
put her little butt to walkins probably
what I'd do but I'm gonna I mean I won't
try everything else first and I sit down
with the two of them and just just
explain to them you know guys you know
we're trying to be reasonable here
but we're dealing with an unreasonable
reaction from both of you and and we are
not going to participate in you bringing
harm to our daughter Bubba you know and
so you need to understand you are you
are messing up your relationship might
your the relationship with this girl you
supposedly care about on her parents by
the horrible advice you're bringing to
her and she's following you like a puppy
and look at her and go you're a puppy
you know I mean that this is the kind of
conversations we've had at the Ramseys
at times it's very uncomfortable but but
I'm not saying I'm just a dad I'm not a
Family Therapist I don't have any idea
if there's anybody else in her life that
has influenced a youth pastor a pastor
or uncle an aunt not appear but if
there's anybody else that has influence
in her life I'd have them sit down we're
there too but I'm not gonna raise my
voice I'm not gonna be angry I'm not
yelling at people I'm not doing any of
that kind of stuff but I but but you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna step on these
bugs these behaviors and so yeah we
would probably pull the car because
she's not doing with the car we gave her
the car for one purpose education and
work and and she's not doing either one
of those the way we agree so get your
own car I'm not paying for anything not
one biscuit as long as you as long as
you do this stuff and you know because
how here's the thing you know this is
this is a socially acceptable
disagreement but let's say there was
another behavior that was more extreme
and it helps you understand the concept
let's say she was doing cocaine would
you buy her cocaine well no that's
absurd
you wouldn't participate in her
craziness and you'll buy a drunk a drink
you don't do that and so why because we
care about the drunk we don't want to be
a drunk we care about this kid we don't
want her to be $50,000 in debt because
she moved three hours away to go to
school for no reason other than
follow lazy Bubba who doesn't like to
work much you know I mean this is how to
control and so I'm with you I get you it
but I'm sorry for you because it's
heartbreaking to go through this
hold on I'll have Kelly sends you out
strong father's strong daughters I think
it's important your husband use the
relationship he has with her in a
positive gentle very strong way this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]